Today I have come to talk to you about a very interesting thing.
Today we have come to see some such symbols
which are used in your daily to daily life
and are also used in chemistry,
so let's see the number one symbol that
you have often used in your daily life.  If
you have seen some of this today, where have you seen it in daily life?
See, when there is a train number,
you must have seen that there is a 1 2 3 4 Up 1 2 3 4
Down number, then
this symbol is used in the train number.  And
in chemistry,
this same symbol is used to show reversible reaction.
Similarly, where have you seen this symbol in your daily
life? You use it daily to
save your data. It
represents the mobile data in your mobile.
This is the symbol and we use this symbol to
represent the electron in the orbital in chemistry. It was
very interesting.
If you know about other such symbols then please answer in the comment box.